hey
luke tom and nate here with the outdoor
boys youtube channel and we're here with
jake and his boys from how to alaska and
we're here
in the arctic wilderness of alaska and
we're gonna be doing some awesome
camping we're gonna go
ice fishing we're gonna camp in a hot
tent we're gonna hunt muskrats
we're gonna blow up tons of fireworks
are you guys ready
[Music]
oh we're in it now check it out how
beautiful this is
we got the matanuska river right over
there but uh
somewhere over there is a lake that
we're gonna go camp on
and uh we're gonna take the snow
machines across the ice
should be plenty thick but you can see
where there's overflow
because there's moving water under the
ice it pops up in weird places and
causes overflow so we're gonna
try to keep our snow machines on the dry
side
hey nathan you enjoy the snow machines
come on nate let's go
i just saw hair yeah right here
you want to shoot a rabbit all right
the tracks all over the place this is
his tracks right here
these are all snowshoe hair tracks
that's real fresh
there's rabbit poop
all right guys let's come let's go back
to the snow machines well that was a fun
little distraction but i think we're
gonna keep going
jake was very kind and volunteered to go
and check to make sure the ice was safe
oh this is gorgeous
this looks like a gorgeous spot i think
we should go
camping hey check it out there's a otter
slide
see you can see where the otter's been
sliding down on his belly into the water
yeah a little bit of fish and poo
there's a spring comes in right here so
that's where there's open water so
that's how they get it under the ice and
they fish
they pull themselves up i never wanted
to see anything
oh yeah
all right if you're focused on one
you'll do
room to have guests you guys starting to
fire over here
let me let me give you a little help
here cotton balls with vaseline that's
what you want man
put that thing right under there
oh you're good wait that was
yeah yeah it's it's good and it'll burn
for a while because of the vaseline
you better get some more wood on top of
that
no important nathan we get out here
starts complaining about his feet being
cold i'm like why you have a pair of
negative 60 boots
i look over and he's not wearing his
boots he's wearing his rain boots
and it's about 10 degrees outside so we
have got to get him
warm okay so i've got some hand warmers
here
okay i'm gonna put his camping
booties on i'm gonna get him in a
sleeping bag with some hand warmers
slide down inside there okay
would you like to watch a show while you
warm up sit down on the thing and take
your boots off
get in as deep as you can i can zip you
up you just stay there and get warm for
a second i need to
put the stove together then you'll be a
lot warmer
all right we got a roaring fire in here
and it feels amazing
my hands were getting so cold trying to
roll that
that titanium
there we go stick your boots here by the
fire
oh it is still warming up in here
[Music]
oh you caught one oh that pretty little
trout right there
well while i'm inside fussing with the
stove jake brought firewood
and cody caught a little trout look at
that
a little dinner there
cooking up those little salmon yep look
at that little guy
[Music]
oh my glass is fogged up come on in
you can feel the heat already nathan you
awake
he's like i got the phone though take it
out in here it's nice
i think nathan has been pouring liquid
nitrogen into his boots these are the
coldest
boots in the world so we are going to
sit him
sit them here by the stove in the hopes
that they may
warm up here who's next
and then you come out but the stove has
melted enough to fill up the lake
then the lake isn't that just
entertaining
i absolutely love these lights this is a
bicycle light
that comes with a gopro mount and these
battery packs that you strap to your
bicycle frame
and instead i just hook them up to my
tripods
or my other gopro mounts it will run
about 12 to 16 hours on the low setting
or at a thousand lumens it'll last about
four to six hours these are
awesome for portable work lights there
you go
oh catch and release oh i could see them
down there yeah they're going nuts i
think they like that light
there we go let's get this fire up and
going and i'm going to get some dinner
cooking
keep here all right let's get some
dinner going
i have a bunch of short pork ribs here
soaking in bubugi sauce
and we've got a bunch of fajita
vegetables and tortillas
so we're gonna be making a little korean
uh tex-mex fusion here
with bubogi fajitas
so this is my ice fishing chisel i
forged it before we came up on this trip
and it's got a chisel on one end and a
scoop on the other but it works good for
a lot of things
[Music]
i got a knife five probably
[Music]
i've got an idea there we go korean
bubogi
pork rib fajitas
oh that's good they're kind of sweet
instead of spicy
really really good best korean fajitas
you've ever had
hey nathan what do you think you like
your fajita yeah
good all right guys we got some fajitas
in our belly i think it's time to shoot
off some fireworks what do you think
there we go got a little berm so if the
fireworks fall backwards they won't
shoot it back towards us
this is oh just fireworks he didn't
buy many fireworks i literally thought
oh a three packs of roman candles
no no everybody over everybody all right
here we go
we're talking serious here holy mackerel
i feel like this can ward off invading
armies yeah it's cold out here
this is awesome yeah
look
hey
that was awesome was that cool
are you okay there yeah we got a
thousand
firecrackers here
whoa whoa
[Music]
that was awesome you guys want to all
light up roman candles
here everyone grab one
we're going to run around the lake real
quick and set a bunch of muskrat traps
tonight
see if we can't maybe catch and eat a
muskrat later on there you go
you've said a few of these huh on my
fingers too this right here is a con of
bear trap muskrat goes through
blink and it gets them yeah i i had a
double spring kona bear 110 and i
caught my fingers in it once got a
bucket full of cottage bear traps we're
gonna get us some muskrat
so right here we have a muskrat feed hut
yeah look at that it's just like a big
pile of grass that they've stuck in the
ice
so if you're ever in a survival
situation you could always ice fish
through these
oh look at that as they get up
in this tube and then they kind of get
on the shelf and then they eat their
food
outside of the water where they can have
a breathing hole oh that's a good sign
you see that
bubbling bubbly
hop on bud
[Music]
you can't remember how it goes but oh
oh you see that yeah i would have fallen
through
they're coming in this way and they're
sitting on their little edge over there
yep
oh
uh let's do this be a tough catch here
but
oh you guys had a good time didn't you
yeah we i just had a bomb
well we just got back from setting the
muskrat traps and the temperature has
dropped to negative
eight or about negative 22
celsius it's nippy guys it's getting
colder
frozen marshmallows look put your boots
down
look at that sucker is that did you even
cook that
not even brown on the outside i think
you just ate a frozen marshmallow
you know what i i gave you a perfectly
good stick i gotta get my boys out here
that's yours more trustable
see you tomorrow
well jake and his boys just left to go
home and sleep in their warm beds
so it's uh just us out here tonight
why don't you sit here by the fire and
stay warm and i'm gonna go in and get
your bags already okay
real easy
i got the door of the stove facing
towards my bag and i've got a pile of
wood
within arm's reach but i don't know
how much i'm actually going to use the
stove in the middle of the night i just
don't know if i want to be stoking it
all night
we can see here inside the tent on the
floor it's about 22 degrees fahrenheit
maybe 25
and if you look at the walls you can see
there's frost on the inside of the walls
below about here so from about here
below is 32 degrees
and the higher up you go in the tent the
warmer it gets until it feels like 70
degrees up here
okay okay all right tom
sit down on the buffalo high
i'm putting on these down booties to try
to keep my feet warm in my sleeping bag
all right guys it's pretty late i'm
going to bed
i'll see you in the morning we'll see
how this goes
well guys we survived the night and look
who's up
hey tom you're nice and warm mm-hmm
how about you look at all the snow on
your mat
see from the from the frost on the tent
it was a little bit of a rough night
last night
around midnight tommy sits bolt upright
in the sleeping bag and starts screaming
his head off
by the time i get him down nathan's
screaming and crying
it took me forever to wake him up i had
to pull him out of his sleeping bag and
pat frost on his face to get him to wake
up
and stop screaming and then tommy
started screaming again
yo about about an hour and a half later
we got everyone to stop screaming and
stay asleep
i did not scream yeah you totally did
twice well i wasn't planning to but i
kept the stove going all night about
every two hours
it would start to get a little cold in
here and i would kind of wake up and i'd
reach over and
grab a log from the log pile and throw
it in there and then go back to sleep
and about two hours later that would
happen and
but yeah we kept it kept it warm all
night long
now it's going pretty good it's pretty
toasty right now
we're killing some time till the sun
comes up we're just gonna watch some
battle bots on our phone
all right we're almost 32 degrees
so right hovering around freezing inside
the tent so
that feels warm look how covered and
frost my
overalls are oh these pants are cool
look at this it is cold out
not a cloud in the sky when the
temperature drops
all the clouds fall out outside the tent
it's negative 16 degrees fahrenheit
that's negative 26 celsius
oh it's cold today man we better get a
fire started out here
well welcome back yeah all right cody
you want to go
do some ice fishing let me get this open
for you
this is the alaskan fish finder right
here stick your face in the hole and see
the fish
it works you can see them down there oh
cody what do you got here look at that
beautiful dolly garden right there
nice one of the creepiest things about
camping on frozen lakes is that the ice
moves and it cracks it's like plate
tectonics
on the ice and last night we had a
couple
really big cracks where we're sitting in
our sleeping bag it all said boo
you can hear the ice move and growing
underneath us
wake up this morning and look at this
crack
right past the tent
i mean they're harmless it's not like
you're gonna fall into the ice it's 18
inches of ice
but it wakes you up and freaks you out
all right jake's run off to go grab
another dead tree and
i'm gonna start chopping some wood get
this fire going
i want to play snow machine tag that's a
lot of wood
we got a bag of scotch eggs and i've
mostly cooked them up already so we just
need to heat them
i've stole your chair
[Music]
dad yeah caribou sausage right there
folks
here tom why don't you try some caribou
sausage this is what the caribou cody
shot
i love it that's it's good
[Music]
there you go scotch eggs got a
hard-boiled egg covered in pork sausage
and deep fried with panko oh it's one of
the most delicious things ever when it's
warm
i did a video on how to make campfire
scotch eggs as part of my 23 campfire
recipes
video and i'll put a link in the
description to that video definitely
check it out
these are delicious so
so you know like there's a difference
between the right
you like
[Music]
you like that nate well both the boys
are sitting on the snow machines making
engine noises i think it's a sign that
they really want to go out on the snow
machine
all right i think we're gonna go check
out those muskrat traps
[Music]
no nothing there
[Music]
nope all right well we're going to cover
it up so we don't kill them all
[Music]
oh we got a little weed in it we
definitely had muskrat action there
runs it out we got one more oh yeah of
course i hope we get one
nope no well we didn't get to eat any
muskrats but that was still pretty cool
well i think we're gonna start heading
back to camp and breaking down camp here
in a little bit
got a long way to go to get home oh
all right i'll tell you what this tent's
been a good little tent for us
i'm actually really pleased with it it's
super light it only weighs about four
pounds for the tent and the stove
the stove is made out of titanium and it
like weighs less than a book
but uh it's a seek outside four man
teepee hot tet
and i'll put a link in the description
to it but i need to start packing it up
and getting ready
to go because uh we're gonna run out of
daylight here in a little bit
we've been hearing more of those big
cracks in the ice and look at it
one of them runs right through my stake
in the center of my tent
probably the heat from the tent expanded
the ice and made it crack right in the
spot
well guys i hope you enjoyed this video
as much as we enjoyed filming it
if you guys want to see more camping
adventures from the outdoor boys youtube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every saturday
morning
and check out our camping adventure
playlist with all of our best camping
videos click
subscribe nailed it and don't forget to
check out jake's youtube channel
how to alaska i'll put a link in the
description to their stuff
thanks for watching guys see you next
saturday if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching